it'd be cool if I could die coming
somehow that's exactly what I was going
to say I want to be in sex I even think
I I don't even want to have sex though I
want to be I want to be in the hospital
where it's
like and then I just start
[Music]
busting welcome back everyone to another
very very special episode of the careful
boys where today in the house we have
not only suben going clap for him hey to
be to be we have our Kawaii cutie boys
wearing matching t-shirts we got Bart
Nick over here brought to you by Red
Bull was our purpose not brought to you
by Red Bull just in case we have a
different ad read and we also have on
this side Joe Colleen and just Michael
in the building hey we are the three
white
[Applause]
girls hey Ken say hi hi Ken Ken say hi
dude yes you can all right no just stay
stay in there don't come out don't come
out okay so for this off the Record
topic all right everybody get your
thinking hats on imagine that you could
choose when and how you die at what age
would you like to die there's no maximum
age here and how would is it a numerical
age how old what do you mean like and
how would you die like the number the EO
Empire yeah is it like a numerical age
or is it like uh I want to die during
the age of my debilitation you know like
is it a a you choose a number well you
could also choose how you would like to
go so if you don't want to have some
sort of of debilitation then you don't
have to I'm going to die at 200 years
old heroically in a bionic Warfare I'm
going to be biomech versus AI robot nice
wow why do you want to die like that my
answer is way more boring because I want
people to remember me I not think I'm
big enough yeah so you want to be
remembered as well this era is going to
remember me as the le guy as a what the
lied guy oh okay okay I think I know
what you're saying can you say what do
you think say Ben is that what that
means yeah the Ben
diagram I can't I know what are you more
lost now right oh there it
is just go with me last cuz my answer is
pretty pretty Comm oh that's really good
I am I am a fire retardant I stop all
fires yeah that's pretty good that's
very that's very good actually the way
you connected that so this era all right
I I I kind of planned it out I'm the
people recognize me as the guy that does
jokes on YouTubes right okay you're that
guy then the next era when AI take overs
okay we're going to have such good
technology infinite Infinity lives
whatever all you guys going to die cuz
you guys weak I'm going to I'm going to
decide to go with the group that says
yes download [__] like the neur link
group yeah I'm like yo what you want to
put a keyboard on my dick go ahead you
want to put that's the first question
they always ask how many letters can you
you want to put a unicycle on my leg D
yeah put a unicycle on my leg like what
about numbers lobster claws bro like
whatever calculator on my butt crack
whatever dude like all that
stuff places yeah nice and then I'm
going to be the super soldier that has
to fight the AI robots that took over M
so you're you're like you're like Will
Smith ey robot versus like the regular
robots yep mhm what what about the
regular robots that have like feelings
and stuff though aren't you going to
like empathize with them that was the
whole premise of that no cuz we're going
to be now feelings huh like the the
humans are going to have so much
electronics that our feelings isn't
going to be as like what it used to be
and I just feel like over time
everything will become less sensitive I
hope so okay h that's not dark at all I
feel like the longer you live the less
sensitive you become yeah that's true
what about Society though is a society
more sensitive all the W [__] would
die by that point though they won't
survive they won't make it wow they're
too worried about their own feelings am
I right they died by their feelings yeah
yeah that makes sense oh yeah but that's
if I I would like to die that way but
then like you know what most people are
going to say oh I wish I die a peaceful
death in my sleep yeah that was my
answer [__] I mean that's kind of lame
like [__] but here I only want to die
that way if I'm
like if I'm like a healthy 8090 and I'm
still like working out and like living
my life then I'm I'm good but if I get
to a point where like my health is
deteriorating and I can't remember [__]
like I want [__] on yourself every
day you got to wipe your butt yeah I
don't want to be I don't want to be a
detriment to somebody else you don't
want to get a keyboard dick I mean that
sounds kind of tight with with numbers
with numbers and letters could at just
say on the keyboard dick just four
letters that's [__] brilliant that's
like offwhite I don't really like that
label you know what I mean but how do
you start it over again if there's no
control all it's uh each each letter is
programmed in a certain pattern to have
a function big thumbs up but would
anyone say oh oh oh I want to die in a
fiery death I want to drown to death
yeah that's hard maybe I want to get
blown up yeah I don't think blown up
might be kind of cool what do you what
what do you want how do you want to
I would want to go out in a war and what
age too 50 50 really is that like next
year what's up I look that old bro wait
why 50 because at 50 I believe I've
already achieved everything I needed to
do before 50 and at 50 I was like 60
[__] that don't sound fun what about
what about kids you might have a
15-year-old still needing a father M
Life Insurance baby it's already taken
care of at 50 I would want to go out of
war and go on a crazy Mission and just
like record myself like all right guys I
love every one of you guys for my
country and boom in the biggest Mission
as subin's running into battle he slips
and he hits his head on a rock and
that's how he goes out has nothing to do
with war at all y what's the what's the
moment is it what's the war about is it
why you it's this same War it's this is
the war son it's the AI War more is when
he's 200 yours is when you're
5050 because Joel lived because of me
he's a time traveler he say he wants to
be 200 I'm at 50 the reason why he's at
200 is I'm pulling him back like Joe and
I remember him Joe yeah and then he died
and then now I have to live till 200 so
a robot shot you right now blew me up
robot blew you up robot damn stupid
that's pretty wild you saved my life
yeah that's why you're 200 you won't be
remembered though Joe will remember I'll
remember and I'll be like for stupid
yeah but will you because you don't
really have feelings anymore yeah
remember your I memories but that's what
triggered the feelings oh so now it's a
ripple effect going the opposite this is
uh this is really script writing there's
a war going on right now you can
probably sign up for and die for but
you're not 50 yeah that's true you're
not yeah you still got plenty of years
dude life insurance okay no no no no how
do you you sometimes when I'm oh man
I don't know I probably want to like die
while
floating say while dancing you know like
you know a place where it's
like floating just drowned like those
planes that go like this in your
anti-gravity no like uh there's like I
don't know where it is some country but
it's like the sky and the water meet and
it just looks like all blue looks like
heaven already imagine I just float and
I just die peacefully and then turn into
a tree isn't that exactly where like
they got the [__] Soul Stone and
[__] The Avengers so you to die in
the ocean I don't know I just want to
die somewhere pretty or I can like look
at like eyes calm but how how are you
dying how old are you oh like 150 that's
an old age okay
200 I don't know it depends I've been
thinking about would you guys take the
would you guys take like some type of
like drugs or whatever to like live
longer if you like if you stay younger
but all of your loved ones don't take it
so you have to experience every single
level well you just got to love new new
things I thought about that but I don't
know it's I don't think I would take it
yeah I wouldn't take it I would I would
take I'm not trying to go to Eternity
your kids I'm just trying to go to my
see my great grandchildren that's all
what if fizer made it you still take it
or Mna made it hell no I'll go for fiser
over M hell yeah give me like 10 of
those no way not those guys
it's got to be a new company at least 15
boosters I Think Jesus that would be fun
because at the end of the day you can
blow your brains out damn so like it's
whenever you want it's whenever you want
yeah okay that's
yeah yeah I don't know sometimes yeah I
watch movies and then you see War film
and then the first guys they open up the
boat like a D-Day and then the first
guys didn't even make it out to pull the
first trigger they just die they're dead
or like I'm just like dude there's like
that sucks that's horrifying I feel like
where we are I think about it all the
time like how [__] lucky are we like
how lucky are we this era you know this
level of safety just walking around you
have abundance of food and then I'm just
like I I guarantee all of our ancestors
at one point was like man if only I
could have some bread today yeah you
know like there was there was there was
a starving someone or someone like
trying to survive someone that's like
I don't know in the forest lost like
there was someone back then dreaming of
the life that we have right now yeah for
real and I'm like that just blows my
mind sometimes thinking about it and
then sometimes I'm walking around I'm
like man that dude's [__] looking
like he's about to die tomorrow like man
that guy looks like he could barely walk
you know how are you standing yeah
sometimes I'm like you're so old you
look like a skeleton with skin and
you're like moving like 2 in an hour
like wow like I'm so lucky I can just
move and my regular speed is like hypers
speed to you do you tell it to their
face I kind of want to sometimes they
don't even know what Joe's saying dude
they can't even I don't even know what
Joe's saying you never you never see
people just on the street and you're
just like I'm so [__] lucky I'm not
you and then you ask them how old they
are and they're like oh I'm 55 and you
go
oh that's so [__] up that's also so
real so you been seen that alamana beach
or something damn that too oh you do see
that alamana it does happen both ways
though there's people I see on the
street and I'm like dude if I socked you
right now you're going to evaporate and
then I'll see another guy I'm like damn
if this guy socks me right now I'm going
to
evapor about you Nick how you going
probably head in the oven head in the
oven no you can't even close the door
Jesus you feel everything yeah you I
don't know man God obviously everyone's
like I want to die in my sleep you know
like that hacky [__] Colleen said um
there's different ways though there's
falling asleep dying or dying midsleep
or sleeping waking up and then dying or
sleeping as somebody stabs you if I had
to go if if I had to fall asleep while
dying it would probably be while I was
driving and I'd like fly off [__]
[__] oh here's here's a question Dam
here's a question which is better would
you rather th die at random not being
able to control it or would you like to
plan the timing this is exactly what
we're talking about right now but which
one which
one if it if if you if if you had to
have preciseness or you don't want to
know that's what I wouldn't want to know
I that would be at the Forefront of my
mind the whole time no I would want to
plan it because like if not then what if
you just die tomorrow then it's like
well I wouldn't know you feel reget cuz
you'll be just like oh get to say bye
and I didn't get to say thank you at
least like if you get to plan it you can
be like I can do this this oh yeah
that's true like you got your bucket
list you don't have to worry about dying
if you didn't accomplish it and you died
you ain't worrying about it anyway cuz
you're die you don't worry after death
me and Michael are going to plan our own
deaths he got ghost regrets but then but
then when you're like 5 years away
you're going to be like [__] I Got 5
years away when you're four years away
you're like damn I only got four years
you can choose but you better live it up
you better [__] you count down do
wheelies everything barbecue pretty
stressful too though knowing when you're
going to die you might be like F I only
got 5 years left am I going to be a lazy
[__] go to sleep or keep doing what I'm
trying to work on my goals to work on my
goal or like he said though if you know
that you can't die tomorrow cuz you're
going to die five years you can do
anything true I'm just going to jump
from this building this that's tying
that's tying that topic with being
Invincible true right that's different
that's how he lives his life cuz you
can't oh I'm not going to die tomorrow
here I'm going [__] pull the trigger
both times it doesn't work
what oh invincibility is different
[__] Ty what's his name Tyrese and
[__] Fast and
Furious you changed the rules man you're
the one who changed the I didn't change
the rules invisibility is I just
furthered the question that you brought
up hey so speak what's the question I
brought up you said if you could choose
how you're going to die and when how
would you do it and when yes 50 right
yeah 50 what about you Bart I think I
think it's got to be I want to be
over 95 so old because my grandpa passed
away at 95 so I feel I got to beat him
because I feel I'm supposed to yeah you
you're probably going to be a stronger
95 though yeah I think so and then so
maybe 100 that'd be cool and it'd be
cool if I could die coming
somehow that's exactly what I was going
to say I want to be in sex I think I I I
don't even want to have sex though I
want to I want to be in the hospital
where it's
like and then I just start busting
Oh I thought you were like having sex
with your partner I'm like how traumatic
no no no no no no no but your partner's
a robot it's okay the robot wars have
already be I want to be by myself but I
just want to be busting all over the
place I just want to scare the doctor
I've never seen this before dude I think
Bart won this game he won the game why
unless you have something better I
didn't go yet I didn't go yet so I don't
know if we won the game or yeah yeah so
unless you have something better okay I
want to die at
96 and I'm busting every
yeah but through my butt dude is that
possible to come dying no to come that
old to come that yeah when you got
[__] keyboard dick of course viaga
everything bro it works dude you can
always come bro I thought it like
stopped working at a certain age I don't
know do you guys ever get curious cuz
you know they say there's a G-spot from
the back no this not what this OTR are
you guys ever
curious but as a as a heterosexual male
meant to go here as a heter no as a
heterosexual male you probably will
never feel it do you feel fomo fomo is
too strong word but yes am I curious
yeah sure why not so would you try to
poke around the corner to see what's
going okay if you're just trying to
valate the fact that you did before in
the shower I didn't do that yes you did
I didn't hit the Jelly Bean you didn't
hit it but you tried you hit that spot I
didn't hear the [__] prostate or
whatever I didn't hit that I clean I
cleaned my butthole he cleans his but
hole like this far in his finger I
didn't punch the beam back pass the
[__] first Notch is already
illegal just doing that is illegal next
to your butt yeah I don't know about all
that flag was thrown this is sodomy past
that yeah what about you Micha you
taking it out the butt before huh huh
huh this is a JK have you ever pressed
on the bean
bag I don't know oh that's a yes that's
a resounding yes that might be I have I
don't know have you has your girl ever
asked no my girl's 40 years old she
doesn't do that kind of
[__] you know what's even more [__] up
is when your girl just when she puts a
finger in your butt just because she
knows you get all squeamish and skittish
but not because she gets pleasure out of
it that's [__] up girls from my
generation don't ask for consent that's
your generation they just do it and I've
been violated that is
true she pushed the bean back they tried
wait what is the what is this bean bag
we just talking about the B the
legendary prostate like inside yeah
inside no you never heard about the
legendary it's never been through cuz
it's supposed to be you press it and
then you just jizz uncontrollably
because that's where your like an
instant Act of like it's the male gspot
but but heterosexuals usually don't
experience that because there's no one
pressing our and you know what now that
you say it I am jealous yeah D you would
try it I I don't know if I say that
exactly I just would like to know
without trying it is that is that
selfish is that too much to ask you got
to do the whole thing you got to do the
whole thing all right honestly before I
die maybe once one time with who hey
don't get personal all right hey just
ride a motorcycle that's how it feels
like it probably does the vibration
that's what sometimes maybe that's why I
feel like oh right are you busting you
bu that's why you don't
he
baby are you every single time you stand
up your pants are wet
that's what I'm saying you have't hit
the legendary spot that all the game
about it's it's like a little ticklish
because of the vibration that's just
flirting I'm talking all the way we're
talking [__] home based Grand Slam oh
no sorry all right my bad that's the
important part of this prompt what were
we talking about cbor our old how death
and how our old roommate was asking of
asking us if we think her boyfriend was
gay at the time because every time he
wanted [__] she had to stick a
finger up his butthole so was asking us
is that is that's asking too much of a
she was like is my boyfriend gay and
then we were like I have no idea that's
complex but that's is your roommate
Mo I tell you straight up if I enjoyed
it my body is a [__] science
experiment bro your body a temple boy
did you answer the question to how you
would die it's boring now answer no
what's yours give us the clip not we got
2 minutes it could be real that's what
you want I just I just think that I
would love to see great grandchildren
that's all just by that age cuz I think
that that's already but how would you
die how would I die how would you want
um it would be sick to be a hero as well
you know what I mean I wouldn't want to
feel too much pain so explosion is our
it's I don't I let me be unique maybe
I'm [__] there's a giant building
fire or something like that and I'm
pulling everybody out and on the last
one boom and I go down and then they put
my name up on a little plaque on the
what about uh notebook style you and
Nina oh why she got to die too man oh
you want her to live you want you want
to die and have her live someone's got
to carry his memory if we do that then I
pass out one second before her oh yeah
so she could feel one second of pain no
exctly so I have I have no no pain at
all that's different right then why are
we same time hey hey stop being on
technical sign would you want to go you
were
the do I want to go before after my
spouse well the difference is I'm 6 and
1/2 years older than her so it's not
fair for her to die before me that' be
wrong oh okay that's a good way to like
but what if she's unhealthy that's
why yeah you know you know Anthony
sometimes life isn't fair yeah well in
this [__] fantasy okay you go die
peacefully in your sleep
okay you go be a hero with your little
plaque we're heroes over here hey like
dude I didn't know I could be a hero and
die we're heroes right you're going to
be on that plaque at the community
center that's like all old and [__] like
a old trophy case and nobody even
remembers of these
[__] who's Anthony Lee you have
a calculator for an [__] all right
it'll come in handy though YMCA oh my
God I'll be getting G-spot stimulated
through my
calculations